you know we teach people the skills how
to do their jobs we teach business
school students how to read a p l but
we're not doing a good job of is
teaching leadership we teach management
but we don't teach leadership and
Leadership is that very human skill that
awesome responsibility to see those
around us rise that's what leadership is
and that requires human skills I despise
I detest The term soft skills when we
talk about hard skills and soft skills
those things are opposite this is hard
skills the skills I need to do my job
better and human skills the skills I
need to be a better human and thus a
better leader and you need both human
skills include things like listening
we don't teach listening but we can
teach the skill set on how to have
difficult conversations oh and by the
way if you can have a difficult
conversation about race you can have a
difficult conversation about pretty much
anything that happens before